on continue cette suite avec notre
invité valises au bonjour vous êtes la
directrice artistique de l'ensemble
vocal de saint quentin en yvelines on
vient de diffuser ce reportage sur la
chorale ukrainienne et je voyais
regarder avec attention parce qu'on va
prestations effectivement avec vous ça
vous impressionne c'est l'ukrainienne
qui ne chante qu'en ukrainien totalement
parce que la langue est pas facile et
vraiment je les admire beaucoup alors
vous aussi c'est pas facile la langue
quand on chante en allemand ce que ces
deux cas du répertoire qui va être
donnée par votre ensemble les 2 et 9
décembre prochains dans l'occasion de
deux concerts là un voisin le 2 et à
magny les hameaux
le 9 autour de bach et j'ai envie de
dire la famille bach c'est le jeu des 7
familles c'est le jeu des 7 familles on
demande le grand oncle en premier
puisque dans la famille bakrie cette
génération était musicienne donc il faut
savoir vraiment qui il a été baigné dans
la musique que dans sa vie n'a pas été
facile puisqu'il a été orphelin dès
l'âge de 10 ans qu'il a été recueilli
par un de ses frères et qu'en fait on va
décliner l'ensemble de cette famille un
peu spécial qui aimait et louer dieu
parce que ça c'était vraiment leur
passion et comme c'est le moment de
l'avant on a trouvé que c'était un très
joli programme à proposer dans cette
période de fêtes
et puis bien évidemment tout ça et en
allemand comme vous l'avez dit c'est pas
toujours facile donc ça sera des
commandes des concerts commentés ou on
expliquera justement le pourquoi du
comment de l'oeuvre est sûre donc
augmenter avant avant le début du
concert pour qu'on puisse exactement
soccer entre chaque pièce il ya eu des
commentaires comme ça c'est des concerts
des 2 et 9 décembre on va s'intéresser
avec vous sur l'ensemble vocal qui a été
créée en 95 vous en assurer la direction
artistique depuis la création en 1995
autrement dit vous êtes passionné par
les donc de votre ensemble vocal il
regroupe je crois une trentaine de
choristes totalement on et 32 très
exactement 32 puisque il y a quatre
pupitres dans une chorale les opran des
altos suivant les voies confiante et les
chaque personne représente vraiment un
pilier dans l'effectif de la chorale
c'est à dire que chaque personne à des
cours de chant au sein du coeur pour
avoir une bonne technique d'aucun alors
ça veut dire que quand même quand on
vient chez vous il faut d'abord savoir
un peu chantée ce qu'on peut chanter
sous sa douche et se trouvait
parfaitement bon chanteur après
bon c'est autre chose quand on se
confronte aux voiles alors une telle
musique aviez la réalité musicale c'est
à dire qu'on a beaucoup de programmation
donc il faut plutôt savoir un peu lire
la musique ou en tous les cas avoir une
bonne mémoire musicale et puis avoir un
joli timbre de voix et vouloir en fait
construire ensemble ça se travaille
rassurez moi ça se travaille
on a un prof de chant qui s'appelle
claude masse aux qu'on aime beaucoup et
qui vient travailler avec les choristes
pour la voix et le timbre de la voix
oui ça veut dire que les répétitions ont
lieu très souvent du coup ci alors les
neuf éditions a lieu tous les jeudis
soirs au prisme
il ya encore éventuellement à elancourt
exactement il ya éventuellement encore
une petite place d'alto s'il ya une
petite dame qui a envie de chanter à une
dame uniquement une dame ou à monsieur
monsieur nous attendons évidemment oui
tout à fait ou un alto voilà exactement
et puis dans notre programmation de
l'année et bien nous allons de rendre un
hommage à andrée chedid qui est une
femme poète geagea chercher le rapport
avec la musique et bien vaslui beaucoup
de compositeurs se sont penchés sur ces
textes et alors là on sera en français
et ça sera bien agréable par contre la
difficulté c'est que c'est du répertoire
contemporain et ça aussi c'est une
spécificité dans son bocal sur la ville
nouvelle
on s'est constitué comme coeur parce que
la ville est nouvelle et nous enchante
de la musique nouvelle
ah oui c'est plutôt sympathique comme
comme lien et oui ça a été l'origine
alors c'est des textes pas forcément
facile manger chez andrée chedid c'est
de la très belle paysages d'hiver
effectivement vous dites c'est en
français donc c'est plus simple qu'à
comprendre qu'en allemand ça c'est
surfait sur mes musiciens en plus qui
sont ceux qui se le sont appropriés
comme philippe raynaud comme rosel sont
des musiciens actuels donc certaines
fois avec des difficultés
un petit peu piquante votre répertoire
on le comprend mais les traites
diversifié revoir totalement crêpes
voilà le but du jeu c'est que justement
chaque année en deux à trois
programmation très diversifiée pour que
notre public puisse écouter toutes
sortes de musique avec pour donner envie
aux gens de connaître un petit peu mieux
ensemble vocal de 50 ans ne vous pose ce
premier extrait
ouais
tél
m
il
chat
un petit mot valais région sur son bien
d'entendre là ce sont des enfants elle
exactement puisque et au théâtre de
saint quentin nous avons la chance que
la scène nationale nous demande très
souvent dans les programmations et nous
avons dans ces cas là des projets
intergénérationnels c'est à dire que les
choristes de l'ensemble vocal les
adultes parraine des petits pour que eux
aussi est la joie de chanter avec nous
vous êtes en train de regarder ces
images je voyais un peu lever le sourcil
et bien sûr puisque donc en gros on sent
vous êtes une femme exigeante quoi vous
aimez l'exigence on n'aime pas
particulièrement l'exigence de la
qualité musicale oui parce que c'est
c'est clair que la musique mérite qu'on
la fasse le mieux qu'on peut mais en
même temps je trouve que le coeur aussi
a son importance et que les émotions
sont importantes et que quand un enfant
partage des émotions pareilles
même si c'est pas parfaitement juste il
est heureux et j'espère que plus tard il
reviendra dans des chorales quand est ce
qu'on grand huit saisons les prototypes
afin qu'ils voient leur parlez nous un
peu justement de votre parcours qu'est
ce qui vous a amené à l'ensemble vocal
alors en fait je suis chef de choeur de
profession je travaille au conservatoire
de versailles et la ville nouvelle de
saint quentin et bien c'est la ville
vraiment où j'ai débuté tout jeune est
et où on m'a demandé de faire le
parcours technique de la chorale cadence
à voisin qui existe toujours et que je
salue parce que c'est vraiment des
choristes que j'aime beaucoup
toutefois la chorale canon c'était un
très très grand groupe
je me sentais quand même avec la
responsabilité de d'une centaine de
personnes est en fait au niveau du
travail que je souhaite faire c'est plus
l'individu qui m'intéresse donc être
dans un groupe de trente c'est beaucoup
plus simple à gérer pour moi et
musicalement et au niveau justement de
la relation humaine
la qualité c'est pas la quantité bon
j'ai dit que je l'aurais pas trop être
très diversifiés je vous pose maintenant
d'écouter un deuxième extrait non on va
partir d'un complément d'un autre
univers
et
je l'avais dit un autre univers en
amérique latine
un petit mois ont fait le grand écart
avec vous oui exactement on a vraiment
la chance de pouvoir avec des choristes
qui lisent la musique pouvoir lire très
rapidement des partitions là on avait
fait un projet avec la misa criolla avec
l'école de musique de guyancourt qui est
aussi à nos partenaires puisque sur la
vie de nouvelles on essaie vraiment
d'être en dynamisme et oui justement
parlez vous parlez de là on parlait de
la chorale accords signés parce qu'on a
vu le reportage concernant donc cette
chorale ukrainienne vous avez parlé de
la chorale cadence à
voisins-le-bretonneux est ce qu'il ya
comme ça des liens entre toutes les
chorales et définit l'ensemble vocal et
énormément on essaie de faire des
projets inter chorales et
particulièrement à la grande et bien là
la grande chorale de saint quentin c'est
souvent le théâtre de saint quentin qui
est pourvoyeur de d'ateliers et
justement cette année nous faisons un
atelier avec des gens qui n'ont pas
forcément l'habitude de l'univers
chorale et on est en train de monter un
programme qui entraînera le choix des
coeurs pour le mois de juin
et si jamais il ya des gens qui se
disent bas ma foi je ne sais pas ce que
c'est que la chorale et bien qu'ils
aient au théâtre de saint quentin parce
que cet atelier est vraiment ouvert à
tout génial duke anglais envie aux
jambes et le jeudi
jeudi soir tous les quinze jours donc il
faut se rapprocher de marie le venez au
théâtre de saint quentin est tout
simplement aller sur le site de théâtre
de saint quentin mettre un petit mail
comme quoi vous êtes intéressés et voilà
peut-être que l'aventuré va commencer
donc alors vous allez lancer vos appels
donc vous allez lancer l'appel vous
cherchez un alto une alto et vous
cherchez ils ont tellement les gens pour
venir compléter l'atelier chant qui a
lieu au théâtre de 50 en dix mois la
exacte a été immédiate ce sont donc ces
deux concerts je le rappelle les 2
décembre ça ce sera à la salle de la
tour a besoin de boutonneux et le 9
décembre en l'église saint-germain la
très belle église saint germain de
magny-les-hameaux soit impressionnant de
chanter dans une église du bac dans une
église du bac dans une église sa série
somptueux je dois dire qu'en plus on
sera accompagné par antoine ternie qui
est un excellent claviériste et par
marie charlotte d'abord nqi est aussi l
une chanteuse soliste donc ça fera un
très beau concert donc deux prochains
concerts si vous voulez découvrir la
famille bach dans son ensemble on n'a
pas parlé de la place des femmes dans la
famille bach on n'en a pas le temps mais
ça sera une prochaine vont bien mourir à
nous raconter l'histoire des hommes que
les femmes dans la farine ou alors on
n'avait que les
merci en tout cas valérie chance d'être
venu sur ce plateau hors jeu